Okay.
The word apocalypse is the
Greek word apokalupsis.
That is translated as revelation
because that's exactly what it means.
I'm uncovering.
So you,
you will often hear the revelation of
John also referred to as the apocalypse,
cause that's also its
title. Now, one point,
please don't call it the revelations.
I don't know why people
think gets revelations is the
name of the book. It's not,
it's the revelation of John. That's
the title. So the word just means Ian.
Uncovering a river's nowadays in the
modern world to an entire genre of
literature of the ancient world,
most of which is Jewish. Uh,
but there are some maybe Greek apocalypse
things that people would call a Greek
apocalypse or apocalyptic type
literature in some Latin, uh,
texts are in Egyptian or
other Near Eastern, uh, uh,
situations.
But most of what we call apocalypses
come from either an ancient Jewish or an
ancient Christian million.
These,
this kind of literature has
several characteristics.
The scholars have pointed out,
and I'll go over this very briefly,
they tend to be synonymous. That
is, they're set. They're set.
It deepen the past. Like we saw
the book of Daniel. In fact,
Daniel is where we get a lot
of our generic, uh, notions
of what an apocalypse is.
The too apocalyptic.
Most apocalyptic books in the
Bible are Daniel and revelation.
And then there,
there's kind of an apocalyptic world
view that I'll talk about also.
But when we talk about apocalypse,
we're talking about first
that genre of literature.
They're usually synonymous there
ascribed to some ancient hero.
So we have apocalypses, uh, uh,
that are titled after Enoch said to me
by enoc who's lived way, way, way back,
just in the, just after Adam. Uh,
we have apocalypses attributed to
various other old testament characters.
Uh, so the idea as we saw with
Daniel is it's written at one time,
but the author claims to be riding
centuries before. And like we saw Dan,
Dan knew the case. They usually tell you
what's going to happen in the future.
Of course, it's actually in
the past for the writer, uh,
at all up until a certain
point. And then the end of, uh,
the current society or the end
of the world as we know it,
it's not normally the end
of the world entirely.
Usually what it is is a destruction.
And then a resettling,
a recreation of a physical world is just
a called it in the Kingdom of God or
something like that. So they usually
have a chronological span of time.
They have all kinds of images,
angels, demons, sometimes B,
sometimes monstrous kinds of beast,
as in you've seen also in revelation.
And in Daniel,
they're usually constructed as some kind
of narrative that the author will say
something like, I, I was
in a dream and I saw this.
And then this angel grabbed me and took
me to this part of Heaven and took me to
the third heaven or the fifth
heaven or the 12th Heaven.
And then I went down to the deep and
saw the dead. Think don pays in Ferno.
And the,
uh,
the way that Dante has led around into
the different parts of the cosmos.
And they have a cosmology, they
usually have a storied, um,
structure to the universe with several
different layers of heavens and often
several different layers of under a,
underneath the different hell,
hell's or Haiti's. So that's the
genre of the Apokyn of an apocalypse.
There's also the worldview of
Apocalypto CISM we'll call it,
and this is what we use this term
is because Paul, as far as we know,
it never wrote an apocalypse.
And yet his letters show strong
influence of apocalyptic autism.
That is an apocalyptic
worldview. You have, for example,
three different kinds of
dualisms you've already seen in,
in the gospel of John and their texts.
Uh,
how there's a dualism
between good and evil.
They're the good guys and the bad
guys there has gotten their Satan. Uh,
so there's an ethical kind of dualism.
There's also a spatial dualism.
There's a dualism of
up there and down here.
And so you have things that go on,
on the earth are simply shadows of
what's going on actually in the heavens.
It's like every country,
according to Daniel has its own prints.
By that he means some kind
of angelic being. So the
Persian, the prince of Persia,
refers in Daniel two,
some huge angelic super human
being who actually rules Persia.
The Prince of, uh, of Judah 10.
The Angel Judah tends to be
Michael or some other, uh,
Angel that you've probably
heard it like ref Raphael,
but each of the nations has its own angel.
So you can imagine sort of that Russia
has its angel and so then America has its
angel and if Russia and
America where to go to war,
this would be actually simply an earthly
shadow type reflection of the true
reality,
which would be going on as the angel of
Russia was battling the angel of America
in heaven.
So that's the way the world is,
that everything that goes on in our
cosmos is simply a mirror image of these
battles that are going on in the heavens.
So that's another dualism of space.
And then there's of course a dualism of
time. We've talked a lot about how, um,
for Daniel,
remember there's a dualism of
the before time in the aftertime.
So there's the time that Daniel's riding,
which is right up to this.
And then what'll happen
is some big cataclysm will
happen and then according to
Daniel,
the son of man will come down.
Battle against the bad evil
forces overthrow and talk
is the fourth epiphany is
and set up the Kingdom of God.
You have the same kind of structure of
the to the time before in the time after
in the New Testament, except
it's squirrely, right?
Because according say to Paul,
this is what's happened.
You have the now time,
which is still going on and
you had your future time,
which has already started
impinging on the present.
The thing that marks the beginning of
the end time has been the cross and the
resurrection of Jesus.
So Jesus was raised.
What do you have when people
are raised the end of the world,
the dead are supposed to be raised
according to Jewish mythology,
and this is something that
doesn't happen all the time,
and mainly it happens at the end of time.
So the early Christians who were there
were Jews expecting and apocalyptic
kingdom of God to happen that Jesus
probably taught this sort of thing himself
as an apocalyptic prophet.
But when Jesus was killed,
then the whole thing seemed to go arrive
because the Messiah is not supposed to
be killed.
Christians and followers of Jesus though
very quickly believed that they had
seen him after he died, so they believed
they had seen the resurrected Jesus.
We're not going to talk
about what they actually saw.
What happened is from a
historical point of view,
all we can say is that they believe they
saw him raised from the dead and that
meant they thought,
oh,
the end time must have already
started because he was been raised.
In other words,
remember how Paul talks about Jesus as
the first fruits of those who sleep?
That just means Jesus, just the first
apple on the tree in his resurrection,
that Butt and all the rest, but will
be raised when the final end comes.
But for the early Christians,
they believe the end had already to in
some sense started with the resurrection
of Jesus. So that's this
end. But then there's,
they also know the full end hasn't come
because we don't see the Kingdom of God
around us. Those Dan Romans are
still in charge. The, the, the,
the bad evil American government is
still running things in the world.
So this must not be the Kingdom of God.
Maybe the Kingdom of Obama,
but it's not yet the Kingdom of God.
So they,
the Christians expected Jesus to
come back down to come from heaven.
This was called the Paris Ia.
We've already seen it in several texts.
In First Thessalonians for example,
Paul talks about Jesus will come and
then we'll flap in there and meet him.
That's the Pyro,
Sia,
which is a Greek term that just means
presence or coming and we refer to the
time when a king or the emperor would
come to visit a city and all the people in
the city, the important people
would come out of the city,
out of the gates to meet the king and
give him gifts and the king would give
them gifts and then then I'll
accompany the king back into the city.
That's called [inaudible]. It's a purely
sort of political civic kind of term.
This is what early Christians used to
call the coming back of Jesus in his pair
of Ia. So Christians live
according to policy, theology,
right in this middle time of the,
of an overlap of the before and the after.
But that still before and after that you
see of apocalyptic CISM is still there.
So all these different dualisms
are one of the characteristics.
And you can see these sorts of things
even in texts that adopt themselves
apocalypses but they show
influences from these kinds of,
this kind of worldview and is
kind of narrative view of history.
And a cosmology often apocalypses seem
to have served as a form of cultural
resistance.
They make the most sense.
Often if you see them as being popular
among people who either are oppressed by
some more powerful entity, or at
least believe that they are oppressed,
they feel themselves to be
oppressed. So for example, uh,
it's a perfectly natural worldview can,
you can understand how the world view is.
If you believe you're an
oppressed minority and you
can't really fight against
the more powerful entity,
there's no way these early
little Christian groups
or even that the nation of
Israel could rebel against
the Roman empire. And when,
and so the idea is that well,
we will resist them and eventually God
will intervene in history with his angels
and his army and the divine armies will
come and we will fight alongside them to
overthrow the Greeks. Earliest
apocalypses Daniel was talking about,
uh, the Greeks and the Syrians,
the Greco, Syria and empire.
So the Greeks were the
first oppressive power that,
that people thought they
could overthrow this way.
And then of course the Romans become
the more oppressive power later.
So in Jesus' time and pause time,
it's the Romans who are the
enemy that will be overthrown,
but that will all happen.
So it's not always true that the
people who believe in these kinds of
apocalyptic ideas are themselves.
In fact, an oppressed minority.
After all, Ronald Reagan was the
president of the United States,
and he still believed this stuff.
He still believed that God
was going to come any day.
He thought it was going to happen right
then any day now. And God was gonna, uh,
you know,
have a big battle with Israel would be
involved in it and will the different
nations of the earth and then God would
set up the Kingdom of God in Jerusalem.
And so, you know, Reagan talked about
this on the phone with different, uh,
Israeli politicians and leaders.
So how,
how does this make
sense for Ronald Reagan,
the most powerful man in the world
to have this apocalyptic worldview?
Well,
Reagan spent a lot of his life feeling
like he was on the out and feeling like
he was not one of the liberal
establishment of the east
and this sort of thing.
So it doesn't necessarily mean that
people who hold these views are themselves
discriminated against minorities
or oppressed minorities.
But it usually means that they
perceived themselves that way.
Because otherwise if you,
if you really do have power,
you just make the world
like you want it to be.
You overthrow somebody or you wage a
battle and wage war and you fixed the
problem yourself.
It's when you don't have
the power politically or
militarily to fix the problem,
that this kind of worldview becomes
very, um, persuasive to you.
Very believable,
plausible.
So that's what the book of revelation is.
In fact, we use the title of revelation,
the apocalypse as the genre,
as the term for the whole genre
and for the whole worldview.
And it comes basically
from this book because a,
it's the most famous apocalypse
of all, naturally. The one,
the weird thing about revelation though
is that it's not pseudonymous. We don't,
that book says it's just
written by a guy named John. Uh,
it's not the same John who
was the brother of Zebbie.
It's not the same John.
If the,
if there was a John who wrote the
gospel of John and the letters of John,
which we don't really know who wrote them,
but whoever wrote revelation is not
the same person who wrote any of that
literature. This style is too different.
That theology is too different.
It's just clearly not the same person,
but he doesn't claim
to be any famous John.
He just claims to be John and and
so we call him often John the seer,
s e r as you know John the profit
or something like that so he,
he doesn't seem to hide who he
is and interestingly enough,
he doesn't place the composition
of his book centuries in the past.
He actually places it in his own time,
but this is also tells you what's
going on, where he thought he was.
He really believed that he
was right there in the end,
had already begun in a sense with Jesus
and so he doesn't feel the need to pray
to cast back into the past
and pro pro prophecy again,
he sees himself as a
prophetic figure like Daniel,
but prophetic fear not for the future.
He doesn't believe the future is going to,
there's going to be any more future. He
believes Jesus is coming back right now,
so he just places himself
right at the beginning.
It's also a little bit unlike some
apocalypse is because you have these seven
letters in the beginning of the book
that are addressed to seven different
churches in Asia Minor.
But one of the interesting things about
all of revelation is its structure.
I talked about Hebrews,
uh,
last week and I gave you an outline to
the letter to the Hebrews to show you
that it was a very elaborately structured
sermon and Hebrews was very well
written. It's one of the, some of
the best Greek in the New Testament.
Revelation is interestingly structured.
If you, and I'll show you why I say that,
but actually it's not very well written,
but the Greek is almost illiterate
and scholars have wondered about this.
Is it just because the writer of this
didn't have a very good education or some
people have using section,
maybe he's intentionally writing and
kind of a weird way as sort of almost a
form of protest himself
against people in power.
There's different theories about this,
but it's not very good Greek
and it's not very well written.
But it does have a fairly intricate
and interesting structure.
And I call this a structure
of cycles on the spiral.
I've titled Your Outline a spiral outline
of revelation because the story a lot
of people have read revelation.
Well,
let me also back up and explain what's
different this week from what we did last
week. Last week, if you recall,
I spent a lot of time talking
about Hebrews and medieval
interpretation because
I was trying to illustrate
how the historical critical
interpretation of these
texts that I'm teaching you in the
semester is not the only way to do it.
There are other kinds of allegorical,
theological literary ways to read these
texts and those are perfectly fine.
Now though,
I'm completely reverting back to the
historical critical way of reading this
text because partly because the way that
so many people in popular culture read
revelation, especially very conservative
Christians, is to read it about our time.
It's been read over and over again to be
about English wars or World War One or
World War II or most recently in in the
late great planet earth and these kinds
of things.
It's about the Soviet Union versus the
United States of America and everything
that talks about is his, is referring to
what's going to happen in our lifetimes.
So the,
the weird animals,
the locus type things that have the
heads of men and fly through the air.
There are all kinds of modern Christians.
You say, oh, those are helicopters.
The author didn't know what a helicopter
look black in the ancient world.
So he just describe kind of what he saw.
But we know now those are helicopters.
So he's actually describing a big war
that's going to break out around Israel
and in Israel when the whole world's
going to come to this big cataclysmic
nuclear war. And it's all talked
about right here in revelation.
Well obviously I'm not going to do that.
What I'm going to show you
is how historians read this
text precisely by putting
it back in its ancient context.
But one of the things is if you notice
the book of revelation doesn't give one
strict timeline. In fact, it key,
it seems to have cycles of setting
up some kind of weird crisis,
having all these terrible things happen.
And then have something that looks like
a quasi resolution and then starting the
cycle again.
So that's so,
and it ends up being a big cataclysmic,
a crash at the end of the book.
So this is what I call this,
a spiral of cycles that are going
on in the book of revelation.
So first though,
look at just chapters six through eight
and I'm going to walk you through this
very rapidly because you can see something
of the structure of this book right
here. Now this is after you've had, um,
all the kinds of a song,
this,
the letters in the beginning of revelation
than you've had the throne room seem
of God was going to
talk about in a minute.
And all the songs that everybody's saying,
but let's just walk through
this first structure here.
Then I saw the lamb opened,
one of the seven seals and I heard one
of the four living creatures call out as
with the voice of thunder come.
I looked and there was a white horse,
its rider had a bow,
a crown was given to him and he
came out conquering and to conquer.
So this is conquering and
warfare is this first horse.
When you opened the second seal,
now you know what he's going with seals.
You picture this.
Now we've talked about how books were
composed in the ancient world and we
talked about scrolls. Things were in
scrolls, not in books like this, right?
With all the different pages all sewn
together. So what he's imagining,
what he's looking at, he's seeing is
there's this huge scroll in the sky,
you know,
and that and that this angel is his
holding and doing different things with,
well, when you want to
finish a letter or a book,
you roll up the scroll and then you put
a wax seal where the paper that at the
end of the role,
and that seals the book.
So anybody who wants to read
that letter or that book first,
the first time has to break that wax seal.
So that's the seals.
He's talking about.
Other wax seals on a scroll.
And so he imagines that you've got this
girl that has one seal and you can break
that seal and you can unroll
the scroll a little bit.
But then you get another seal so you
under undo that seal and you can enroll a
bit more.
So he's gradually unrolling this scroll
that's going to have all these things
pop out of it.
So this is big,
huge scroll that has can horses and riders
jumping out of it and flying through
the air. He opened the second
seal, I heard the second
living creature caught out,
come and out came another horse,
bright red.
It's rider was permitted to take peace
from the earth so that the people would
slaughter one another and
he was given a great sword.
So if the first seal releases this
horse that it looks like empire,
the conquering of the conqueror.
The second is just general warfare.
When he opened the third seal, I heard
the third living creature collect come.
I looked and there was a black horse.
Its rider had a pair of scales in his
hand and I heard what seemed to be a voice
in the midst of the four living creatures
saying a quart of wheat for a day's
pay and three quarts of
barley for a day's pay.
But do my do not damage the
olive oil and the wine. So the,
the third seal is what?
Famine, famine and poverty.
When you opened the fourth seal,
I heard the voice of the fourth living
creature called.com and I looked and
there was a pale green horse.
It's writer's name was death
and hades followed with him.
They were given authority over the
fourth of the earth to kill with a sword,
famine and pestilence,
and by the wild animals of the earth.
So death is this foursome.
When I opened the fifth seal,
I saw under the alter notice he's,
we're not talking about horseman anymore.
You had four horsemen representing
four different things.
The fifth seal has
something like a digression.
The fifth seal is not another horse
like you expect. In other words,
you're given to expect that
you're going to see another horse.
It's going to be some other catastrophe,
but you don't get that.
You have a digression under the alter,
the souls of those who have been
slaughtered for the word of God.
And for the testimony they had given,
they cried out with a loud voice.
[inaudible] sovereign Lord,
holy and true.
How long will it be before you judge and
avenge our blood on the inhabitants of
the earth?
They were each given a white robe and
told to rest a little longer until the
number would be complete, both
of their fellow slaves. It says,
actually in the Greek, not servants
and of their brothers and this,
and it doesn't say sisters.
There's no, there's no,
almost no women in this text at all.
It's all men,
virgin men who've never been
polluted by touching women.
It's not exactly a pro woman book.
You might not get that idea if you
have an English translation that keeps
putting sisters in here, but it's,
and there are no sisters in this book.
There's the whore of Babylon.
There's the mother bride.
And then there are men,
uh,
your slaves,
your fellow brothers who are soon to
be killed as they themselves had been
killed. So what's the fifth seal? Well,
it gives them a vision of the altar of
God in the Temple of God. In heaven.
There's this big altar and under the
alter the souls of all the followers of
Jesus who have been martyred up to this
time and the souls of those people who
will be martyred and they're not
punished, right? They're saying how long,
how long? And he says, Oh, you know, keep
your pants on. Here's a white robe. Just,
you know,
sit there and be nice under the altar.
We're going to take care of it all very,
very soon.
So the fifth seal is actually a digression
that tells you the audience that if
you suffer in this present time,
it will be taken care of by God.
So he had these four building up of
terrible things and the fifth is a
digression that gives you comfort.
But now we're going to get back.
He opened the sixth seal. I looked and
never came out of her great earthquake.
The Sun became black as sackcloth.
The full moon became like blood.
The stars of the sky fell to the earth.
As fig tree drops its winter
fruit when shaken by a gale,
the sky vanished like a
scroll rolling itself up.
Remember I talked about how the sky
in ancient cosmology isn't just air.
It's actually a firm thing.
It's like a big piece of
leather or something like that.
This that sits up there and there's
water on the other side of it and in most
ancient cosmologies or something on
the other side of it. So when you,
when he talks about seeing the
sky rolled up like a scroll,
he means that quite literally this guy
goes straight, chick, chick, chick, chick,
chick, chick, chick, chick, chick in
rose up. And you can see heaven above it.
So the sky vanished like a scroll.
Every mountain and island was moved in.
It's place than the kings of the earth
and the magnets and the generals and the
rich and the powerful and everyone.
Slave and free hid in the caves and
among the rocks of the mountains,
calling to the mountains and rocks fall
on us and hide us from the face of the
one seated on the throne.
And from the wrath of the lamb for
the great day of their wrath has come.
And who is able to stand? So the
sixth seal is all hell breaks loose.
The Cosmos was coming
down on top of itself.
He's created an increasing level of
anxiety and catastrophe with this,
these sit others. But with that
fifth seal is kind of a digression.
After this I saw four angels.
Now you think, Oh man,
if the sixth seal was like that,
you know one more seal is coming up.
What's the seventh seal going to be?
So you can just [inaudible] remember this.
All this was read out loud in the ancient
world. So you're hearing all of this.
I saw four angels standing
at the four corners,
earth hurting back to the
four winds of the earth.
Now you get a bunch of other stuff.
I saw another angel ascend,
heard the number of those who are sealed.
Oh,
now you have all the followers of Jesus
are numbered into a different tribes of
12,000 piece and each of those tribes
is sealed to themselves in that
interesting.
And you have another use of the term seal.
But now this is a seal that's put on the
the faces of all the people who are the
true followers, who are the true
Israel? 12 tribes, like the 12 tribe,
the lost 10 tribes and the
other two tribes of Israel.
So there's the reconstituting of Israel
now and they're sealed and the seal is a
good thing. It means you won't be
harmed if you have this on you. Okay?
Net goes on all of chapter seven. Now
you're thinking, where's the seven seal?
You know, we had six, I know
there's another one coming.
Where is it? And you, you,
you have to wait all the way through
chapter seven wanting the seventh CEO,
but you're not getting it yet. In other
words, he's just stringing you along,
but he's stringing you along in a
way that's kind of good because he's
reassuring you. You know, the seven
seals come in and you're just,
you're pretty sure it's going
to be really, really, really,
really bad because the sixth seal was,
but before you get to the seventh seal,
you have this ceiling of you.
If you're a faithful follower of
Jesus with the reassurance of a seal.
So you have, and then you have some
songs. We're gonna talk about some songs,
but everybody comes in, you know,
it's like a Broadway play, right?
You have something happen and then the
chorus all runs on stage and they do a
little song blessed to be the lamb in the
pilot, in the power, power, power, power.
Hallelujah. Hallelujah, Hailey. And then
they run off and you have more action.
So that's the way the story is structured
that way. Also, for instance, music.
So we get to the end of chapter seven
we're finally the tender and who gets to
chapter eight of course,
they're not numbered in the ancient world,
but when the lamb opened the seventh seal,
you ready for this? There was
silence in heaven for a half an hour.
That's the seventh seal.
Well, let's go on on this.
The text builds up tension and you hear
this read out loud and it keeps building
up this tension.
But then this,
the seventh seal is such a anticlimax
silence in heaven for a half an hour.
But then it doesn't explain anything
about that. It just starts over.
Then you have another
cycle a little bit later.
Another angel that golden censer came
and stood by the altar. In other words,
what you've got is something like this.
You have these four scroll, the
four seals, which are terrible,
terrible, terrible, awful things.
And then you have the fifth,
which is a digression. And actually
it's actually a good thing. It's this,
it's the telling of the souls have been
martyred. Don't worry, you'll be saved.
Here's a white robe, relax. And then you
had the sixth seal, which is another,
uh, worst thing than all these. It's
really, really bad and it goes on longer.
And then you had this long digression
again, this like five is like,
like the fifth seal. It's a ceiling of
the followers of Jesus with salvation.
And then after that digression,
then you have this seventh seal,
which is really kind of anticlimactic,
but it's not bad because you know,
silence in heaven for a half an hour.
Look at your spiral outline now because
this kind of structure of having a cycle
of catastrophes that are interrupted
every once in a while by some kind of
digression that then
ends with something good.
That's the way the whole book
is structured in several,
in three different cycles.
So for example,
I said in in the fourth
chapter of revelation,
you have the big heavenly
throne room scene,
revelation five you have the introduction
of the scroll with seven seals in the
land and then you have the first cycle
of seven and that's what I just walked
you through just now. But then right
after eight one the silence in heaven,
it starts again with a second cycle and
you have an eight to introduction of
seven angels with seven trumpets. And
then again you have for the first, second,
third and fourth trumpet which
announced these kinds of catastrophes.
And then you have an interlude where
this ego comes through and announces woes
on everybody.
And then you had the fifth trumpet in
Chapter Nine One through 12 and the sixth
trumpet in Chapter Nine Verse 13 and
then you have chapter 10 which has been
another interlude which says that's
about the scroll of Prophecy.
Chapter 11 you have the talk about the
temple and he has to measure the temple.
And then in chapter in chapter 1114
you have the end of the second. Whoa.
And that's one of the third world.
And finally in 1115 you
have the seventh trumpet.
And what does the seventh trumpet
introduce? Praise in heaven,
sorta like that half hour of silence.
And then you have a long interlude,
which is chapter 1213
and 14 which is about uh,
battles between the woman who's the
mother of the church or as a mother of the
savior. And the Dragon. Chapter 13
is about the dragon and the beast.
Chapter 14 is about the lamb, the horned
lamb, which represents Jesus, whose horn,
a horned lamb who has wounded.
And then you haven't an an
starting in chapter 15 verse one,
you have a third cycle of seven
angels and seven plugs are bowls.
And then you have the great conclusion,
which is a very end,
the destruction of Rome and chapters
17 through 19, the final battle,
which is chapter 1911 through 21,
the imprisonment and a mutual
destruction of enemies,
which just chapter 20 and
the establishment of the new
Jerusalem and chapters 21
and 22.
What is this structure tell us because
the structures in these different cycles,
it builds up crisis and
then it gives you something,
a relief at the end.
There's a famous New testament scholar
who teaches at the divinity school.
This time is not me, uh, who
teaches in the divinities goal.
Adella Yarbrough Collins. And many
years ago when I was still a student,
I read this book she wrote called crisis
and Catharsis and it's a wonderful book
about revelation.
And her thesis was the very purpose of
the book of revelation is to build up a
sense of crisis in early followers
of Jesus. If you're, if you're,
if you're too comfortable with your world,
you don't know that things are really a
lot worse than what you think they are.
So if it's addressed to Christians
who are, if they're comfortable,
it wants to make them
uncomfortable with Roman rule,
and if they're uncomfortable with Roman
rule and feel depressed and oppressed,
then eventually the book will
lead them to feeling comfort.
So crisis is created by the book in order
to have let you experience a catharsis
of the salvation and the looping structure
of the book tries to work that out
psychologically in its hearers and
you can see how it's going to do.
So the book is actually,
it's part of the thing about it is
meant to be performed. You, you,
you're hearing it read
out loud is a long book,
but you sit there and you imagine a
bunch of Christians in Asia minor in some
church, say in Ephesus and their meeting,
it's dark. They're meeting in some house,
somewhere in somebody's dining room
and somebody has sent around, uh, this,
this document and ask it to be red.
So you're all sitting around with just
some candles going on and somebody
reading this book and it's got
all these strange things going on,
strange creatures and
a lot of these songs,
the things that people are singing and
angels are singing and beasts are singing
and, and elders are singing.
It started liking that in
the fourth chapter. Look at,
look at the fourth chapter,
a revelation.
And this is where we're
in the throne room of God.
After this I looked and there in heaven
adore, stood open. And the first voice,
which I had heard speaking
to me like a trumpet said,
come up here and that will show you
what must take place after this.
And once I was in the spirit
and they're in heaven,
stood a throne with one seated on the
throne and one seated there looks like
Jasper and Carnelian.
And around the throne is a rainbow that
looks like an emerald and around the
throne or 24 Thrones and seated on the
throne to 24 elders dressed in white
robes with golden crowns on their heads
coming from the throne or flashes of
lightning. Rumblings and peals
of thunder in front of the thumb.
Seven flaming torches where
the seven spirits of God,
you have all that's going on and
then then they, they bake. They,
the four living creatures
are these monsters,
combination kind of monster creatures
are standing around the throne and they
start singing holy, holy, holy. The Lord,
the Almighty who was and
who is and who his do come.
And then you see other the 24 elders
in their singing another song.
The whole thing is meant to be seen
in your mind, not just read silent.
So we're going to do a little experiment
here to show how that might happen.
All right?
We're going to break up into thirds.
You get to be the four living creatures.
Alrighty.
And then we're going to split the rest
of the class right here. Y'All get to be,
I think it's the elders. I can remember,
but, and then you got another group.
So here, these are the quotations. So
here's, I want you to say this with me.
Very soft at first, right? And
don't rush, don't get faster.
I'm a musician. You know I'm going to
make you stick with the tempo I set
holy,
holy is the Lord God Almighty who was
and who is and who is to come play it.
Holy,
holy is the Lord God Almighty who was
and two is and two is to come again.
Holy,
holy is the Lord God Almighty
who was and two is and
worthy is the lamb that was slain.
Worthy is the lamb that was slain.
Don't rush.
Keep doing it.
Glory on or power to the
o Lord Most High Glory.
Honor power to thee.
O Lord Most High Glory honor.
Power to the o Lord Most
High Goolarri under power
to the island. I get a little
bit louder. Good. Laurie on
the smoke in the throne room
[inaudible] there are
beasts flapping their wings.
[inaudible] who was and who is and two
is now close your eyes and get louder.
Is the lamb that was slain
worthy is the lamb that was slain.
Worthy is the lamb that was slain.
Glory, honor, power to the now. Louder.
Laurie.
On her power to the alarm
most louder glory, honor,
power to the our lung.
Mo's Haim worthy is the lamb
that was slang ladders down.
Don't you shouting,
shout it.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
ladder.
Who was s stop.
It feels something.
There's both to feel something.
You're supposed to kind of feel weird.
You're supposed to feel, you know,
uncomfortable. Just a little bit.
You're supposed to feel a little tingle
because reading revelation as if it's a
blueprint for you know,
Jesus coming back and what's going to
happen with the Republicans and the
Democrats kind of misses the point
because what it really is doing,
it's trying to pull you into a
world at very performative world.
That's the thing. This is, it
really is like a stage show,
except as the stage is the whole cosmos
and all kinds of weird things that are
happening all around.
So part of what's going on here to use
professor Collins phrase is it introduces
this sense of a crisis in the,
in the cosmos.
But it doesn't do that because
it wants you to in the end,
simply live in that crisis is because
the author believes God's gonna take care
of the crisis of eventually,
but not necessarily today.
And so the book,
having this book performed in your Church
for you read out loud in the middle of
the night deals with your sense
of persecution if you have one.
But what if you don't have
a sense of persecution?
What of your actually fairly
comfortable with wrong?
What if you're, you know, fairly
well off. You've got a good business.
The Romana them, the Roman peace
actually allows you to travel.
You can get on a ship and not have
to worry about pirates unlike today
or unlock. It was 100 years
before this cause back. You know,
pump pay was the general who,
who cleaned the pirates out of the
Mediterranean in the first century BCE.
So if you're a businessman,
you're a fairly well off.
You might think that the Roman peace,
there's a pretty good thing and sure a
few people's heads got to get cracked
every once in a while to keep the peace.
That's just the way it is. So the,
the letter, the, the book of revelation
seems to have a dual purpose.
It's like that old saying
about what good preaching is.
Good preaching is supposed to comfort the
afflicted and afflict the comfortable.
That's kind of what the book of
revelation seems to try to do.
So could cause notice. What is the
view of, of Rome that you get here?
Look in revelation 18 and 19.
Yeah.
If you got a picture of,
if all you had was the letters of Paul,
what might you think about
Rome? What might you think
about the government? What,
what might you think about the emperor?
If all you had were certain other,
uh,
books such as the pastoral epistles,
what would you think the about
their politics. But with this,
there's no way you could find
this author saying something like,
honor the emperor,
which is precisely what you get in some
other early Christian letters after this.
I saw another angel coming
down from heaven having
great authority and the Earth
was made bright with this blender. He
called out with a mighty voice. Fallen,
fallen is Babylon. The great has
become a dwelling place of demons,
haunt of every foul spirit,
a haunt of every foul bird,
a haunt of every fowl and hateful beast
for all the nations have drunk of the
wine of the wrath of her fornication.
And the kings of the earth have
committed fornication with her,
and the merchants and the earth have
gone rich from the power of her luxury.
This is clearly wrong.
Babylon is the code name for Rome here.
I mean, we know it is because,
and I'm, uh, chapter 17,
verse nine. In verse 18, he talks about
this city as being on seven hills,
referring to the famous seven hills
of Rome. And of course in chapter 13,
18,
uh,
this calls for women for
wisdom, not women, um,
so that no one can buy herself,
does not have the mark of the beast,
the name of the beast or the number
of its name. This calls for wisdom.
Let everyone,
anyone with understanding calculate the
number of the beast for it is the number
of a person.
It's number is 666 what is 666 well,
back in the 80s, some of us left
us, said Ronald Wilson. Reagan are,
you can come up with all kinds
of different other things.
Scholars think that if
you take the word Nero,
the name of the emperor,
uh,
and you spell it in near
Iran with a final end,
like you would a,
in the Hebrew letters,
it comes out to be 666 add
up those three letters.
Now you'll notice there's also a footnote
that says other ancient authorities
say 616 so some scribe comes
along and sees 666 is that,
oh no, that can't be right. It
must be 616 and it's actually,
that makes a lot of sense.
If this is supposed to refer to neuro,
because if you spelled Nero's
name slightly differently
in a way that was still
possible to spell it.
For the ancient world,
it comes out to be 616 rather than 666
which leads a lot of us scholars just to
thank the writers,
probably referring to narrow in some way
and Nero's a beast and Nero is that the
whore, the Rome is the
whore that's, you know,
had sex with every rich man and every
king throughout the whole world.
So this is not a very positive view of
Rome and Rome of course is completely
destroyed at the end. The,
the part about Nero's,
we don't know when this text was written,
some people actually
believe that revelation was
written in the 60s when Nero
was himself.
The emperor more tend to believe that's
written toward the end of the century
when Nero had already been dead.
But this refers to a great myth
from the ancient world called Nero.
Read a V Boosie.
Yeah. The myth was that Nero was
such a terrible, terrible, terrible,
bad man that even though
he'd been assassinated,
he was going to rise from the dead
someday or some people have believed he
wasn't ever a dad. He was just, he escaped
and was off living with the Parthians,
who are these people who lived on the
very eastern corner of the Roman Empire?
So the idea was Nia was
still alive somewhere and he
was gonna raise an army of
Parthians and he was gonna come back and
he was going to wage war and take over
the Roman Empire again,
or he was going to rise from the dead and
raise an army and take over the empire
again. And this was especially chilling
for followers of Jesus because Nero was,
was well known in the end of the century
for being the first emperor to have
persecuted the followers of Jesus in Rome.
The famous story is that, you know,
Nero, there was a big fire in Rome,
and Nero was blamed for
the fire because he was,
he clearing a bunch of
apartment buildings,
have it lower income people
out of a certain area of Rome.
It's right by the coliseum to build
his huge big palace. And in fact,
now if you go to Rome, they've opened
up the Golden House, I call it. And, uh,
this was the palace that Nero built.
Um, and it's beautiful and you go,
you have to go under the ground to get
into it and see it and everything because
now it's all covered by the grant.
But do you go to Rome,
get tickets and go to the new rose palace?
Because it's only in the last several
years has been reopened for the public.
But the idea was Nero had actually burned
a bunch of tenements in our to make
room for his palace.
But because this was so unpopular,
he blamed it on the Christians. He
said, ah, the Christian set the fire,
the Christians are
those really bad people.
And the story goes that he had a big
barbecues in his palace grounds and he put
the bodies of Christians
covered with tar on steaks,
crucified them and put them on
steaks and let them, and they,
they're burning bodies provided
the torchlight for his party.
This is the story that was circulated
about Nero by later Christians and by
other people too.
So for followers of Jesus Nero was
this terrible figure who they were,
thought he might even rise again from
the dead and do battle against us.
So who does all this make sense of this?
The writer is giving this big myth.
Obviously the whore is killed,
Babylon is killed. Romans destroyed.
All the wealthy people are destroyed.
All the kings of the
earth and destroyed by,
by the angels and by Jesus coming down
and then the setting up of the new
Jerusalem with this gold and beautiful.
And there's,
there's no night or day there because
God is light and everybody lives happily
ever after. But what is the kind
of situation if this speaks to,
we're going to go back to the beginning
of revelation. Now look at chapter two.
These are the letters.
Do we know it was written
by a guy named John?
He says he was in prison on the isle
of Patmos in the Mediterranean when he
wrote this.
And then you circulate it around and he
starts off with these seven letters to
seven churches, to the angel of
the Church in Ephesus. Ephesus.
Hmm. We've seen ethicists. Heaven. We,
one of Paul Pseudo Paul's letters
may have been addressed to Ephesus.
Paul apparently did found a church in
Ephesus and it was one of his this bigger
churches.
It seems like he spent years there.
These are the words of him who holds
the seven stars in his right hand,
who walks among the seven golden lamp
shade lamp stands. I know your works,
your toil and your patient endurance. I
know that you cannot tolerate evil doers.
Do you have tested those who claim to
be apostles but are not and have found
them to be false so there's false
apostles want running around.
I also know that you are
enduring patiently and
bearing up for the sake of my
name and that you have not grown weary.
But I have this against you. See,
some of the letters are mainly letters
of praise to the churches and some of
them are scolding letters.
So it's interesting to see what does he
scold people for and what does he praise
them for? Remember then from
what you have fallen, repent,
so this is a back slid church. He
thinks do the works you did at first.
If not,
I will come to you and remove your lamp
stand from its place unless you repent.
Yet this is to your credit,
you hate the works of the Nicolaitans,
which I also hate. While we don't want to
know anything about the Nikolay Athens,
so that doesn't tell us much.
Let anyone who has an ear listen to what
the spirit is saying to the churches,
to everyone who conquers,
I will give permission to eat from the
tree of life that is in the paradise of
God to the, and then it goes onto
another. So there's false apostles.
But then again,
um,
to nine I know your
affliction and your poverty,
even though you are rich.
I know the slander on the part of those
who say that they are Jews but are not,
but are a synagogue of Satan. So there's
this poverty that he's praising poverty.
He talks about people who are Jews say
they're Jews, but they're not two 13.
I know where you are living.
This is to Pergamum,
which happened to be a huge
site of the imperial cult,
the cult to the emperor that you can go
there. Now I'm going to be there in June.
Why don't you jealous and you can
go to the top of this mountain.
The acra Acropolis in Pergamum and the
Austrian are archeologists are rebuilding
all these temples to uh,
um,
to Trajan and Hadrian
on the top of this film.
Of course Trajan and Hadrian
or after he wrote this,
but there was still a big emperor cult
there. I know where you are living,
where Satan's throne is.
Well,
maybe that's a reference to the
emperor cult itself. You are not,
you are holding fast to my name.
You did not deny your faith in me.
Even the days of Antipas my witness,
I have some things against you.
You have some, well, I'm running out of
time, but let me tell you what basically,
he really doesn't like.
He doesn't like a woman named,
he calls Jezza Bell who is one of
the prophets in one of the churches.
He doesn't like rich people.
He says stuff about idolatry,
which makes it sound like he doesn't like
people who are eating meat sacrificed
to idols.
We don't think there are any of these
churches that were actually practicing
pagan idolatry.
What probably going on is he's knows
that there are some Christians who are
eating meat sacrificed to idols
and he calls that idolatry.
Now let's think about which churches are
in this area of western Asia minor that
have women as leaders in them.
They've been told by their apostle that
it's okay to eat meat sacrificed to
idols,
and some of them are not that poor.
Like there seemed to be people in
Corinth who seem to be fairly well off.
Maybe this guy,
and this is just a theory,
but I think it's fun to think about
maybe he's actually writing to Paul's
churches precisely because
he thinks they're too
comfortable with Roman rule and
he wants to make them uncomfortable
with Roman rule in order to turn them
against Rome and to convert him to his
own vision about this anti Roman version
of the Gospel. And that's
why he constructs, as I said,
if you're troubled,
if you feel like you're oppressed,
you're supposed to be
comforted by this text.
But if you're too comfortable
with the Pax Romana them,
you're supposed to be made uncomfortable
by the text and get on the right side.
On Wednesday,
we'll talk about some texts that may have
been more comfortable with Roman rule.